[Música]
o que o steve jobs é óptima e insistem
marie corri santos dumont ela mas que
têm em comum todos eles são pessoas que
têm uma alta capacidade de transformar o
mundo ao redor deles e o mundo como um
todo
certo todos eles têm uma capacidade que
é em nata ou será que apreendida e aí
fica uma pergunta é possível ensinar as
pessoas a serem inovadoras
será que isso é algo inato ou a gente
pode ensinar essa é uma dúvida que eu
tenho que responder a vocês que pessoas
podem ser inovadoras
esse é um processo pode sim ensinar nada
a gente pode trazer isso para as escolas
a gente falou tanto de inovações como
uber ambiente e tudo mais
todas as inovações são feitas fora do
brasil todas as inovações que a gente
usa mas a gente tem que falar também
sobre as inovações que que a gente vai
criar que as crianças quem está tocando
vão ser criadas para fora do brasil
também existem sair do papel somente de
consumidores para também produtores
nessas inovações e como é que a gente
pode fazer isso quais é uma das soluções
um dos caminhos que vai apresentar para
vocês através da aprendizagem mão na
massa
esse movimento maker que vem acontecendo
no mundo que pra quem não sabe que esse
movimento maker
ele é um movimento que vem trazendo
tecnologia e inovação uma outra visão de
como se trabalhar com criação surgiu nos
estados unidos
é numa linha de você poder trabalhar
criar se expressar muito compartilhar
seus projetos utilizando tecnologias que
antes eram fechados ao mundo da
engenharia como impressão 3d cortadas a
laser é e bartels ou não e se não né
esse era já utilizado por todo mundo mas
as escolas começaram a utilizar esse
movimento maker pra poder gerar pessoas
inovadoras como aconteceu nos estados
unidos e começou a espalhar pelo mundo
está acontecendo muito hoje aqui no
brasil também
muitas escolas estão começando a criar
espaços menos espaços de criação dentro
das escolas
e quando a gente fala beleza então vamos
colocar um espaço maker e na escola
vamos criar um espaço de criação
qual é o contexto é pra que serve serve
para três coisas letramento tecnológico
engajamento curricular eo empoderamento
pelo design o que cada uma dessas coisas
né
quando falo de letramento tecnológico eu
tô falando o seguinte a gente está
imerso já falamos hoje muitas vezes que
está imerso e universo tecnológico
sempre como consumidores
a gente esquece de abrir a caixa preta
de entender esse mundo por trás das
tecnologias e quando faz letramento
tecnológico ensinar nossas crianças a
lidar com essa tecnologia de uma forma
crítica então vamos se nela assim o
programa vamos tirar essas crianças sim
a saber em modelar
vamos ensinar sim a trocar o chuveiro
vamos ensinar as crianças a lidarem com
a tecnologia que está imersa na vida
dela
esse é o primeiro ponto segundo
engajamento curricular e aqui mora uma
das possíveis chaves para transformar a
forma como a gente trata a educação na
forma tradicional porque quando falo de
engajamento curricular
eu tô falando a gente criar para poder
aprender o que quero dizer com isso
imagina que seu tom ensino médio eu
tenho que aprender sobre movimento
público
quem lembra que o movimento público em
física imagina se tivesse que aprender
sobre o movimento público construindo
uma catapulta e refletir em cima dessa
construção em cima dos fenômenos que
houve um movimento público terá que
aprender é mais fácil será que não
aprender é mais fácil
tem uma pesquisa de um professor da
universidade de stanford
um brasileiro que se chama paulo
blikstein ele fez uma pesquisa onde ele
colocou os alunos primeiro para
experimentar em depois que o conteúdo
ontem o conteúdo e depois de
experimentarem o resultado dele foi que
os alunos que experimentam antes tem
cerca de 30% melhor engajamento melhor
resultado na evocação do conteúdo do que
quem tem um conteúdo o primeiro
ou seja aí tem um monte de um laço
revelando reboleira lampejo de como pode
ser uma educação muito mais efetiva no
futuro através de criação
então esse é o segundo ponto que elas
possam utilizar utilizar os pais
make como ferramenta pedagógica o
terceiro ponto que é o empoderamento
pelo design que por si só o nome não
explica nada eu vou explicar para vocês
eu te trazer mais o que é tão poderoso
que esse empoderamento design tem que
pode gerar essas pessoas inovadores
só que pra explicar para vocês eu vou
tirar você estamos aqui vou ter que
levar todos vocês junto comigo pra
colômbia ano passado quando eu tive a
oportunidade de participar do ibds
educacional que foi o de s
é um encontro organizado pelo haiti onde
eles sejam pessoas de vários lugares do
mundo que têm a função de e para aquele
lugar
desenvolver tecnologias para melhorar o
desenvolvimento social junto com as
comunidades estão junto com as pessoas
de lá
nossa função era chegar lá o time
trabalhará em bogotá nas periferias para
construir uma tecnologia que ajudassem
na desenvolvimento educacional
ok então vamos lá quem foi eu quem foi
às pessoas que foram trabalhar lá
aqui eu tenho um professor que é da
universidade da colômbia tem um
professor de marketing uma gestora de
uma ong na no peru um designer com a
canadense
o leandro sou eu e ali no cantinho
não sei se todo mundo consegue ver tem a
diana a diana é a professora do colégio
que a gente estava trabalhando
então olha só são pessoas se unindo pra
criar soluções para pessoas
essa é uma das coisas que mais gosta do
de tudo que foi uma foto que a gente
errou quando estava fazendo o processo
de entender a realidade das crianças
e quando falo de entender a realidade
das crianças foi coisa muito chocante
para mim por exemplo 20% das crianças
que trabalham que estudavam no minuto de
deus lá em sua área não votar são filhos
de desplazados que são os casados são
pessoas que têm suas casas dos
campesinos trabalhava no campo e
organizações guerrilhas simplesmente
tirar as pessoas de suas casas e assim
que e promulgar
ela geralmente vão morar nas periferias
das grandes cidades da colômbia bogotá
sendo uma delas a escola estava
trabalhando
por cento nas crianças são filhos
casados e como é que isso entender isso
essas prioridades do ser humano quando a
gente vai falar de melhorar problemas de
matemática é super necessário condição
de seres humanos e gestão de pessoas
construir coisas para pessoas tudo bem
então vamos lá se juntamos e agora vamos
criar
só que leandro não se acha uma pessoa
inventiva
o leandro não se acha uma pessoa ip
criativa
ele consegue se articulado ele consegue
fazer as coisas mas não é não se acha o
inovador e aí eu fui posto
ante esse desafio eu sofri sobre o
processo de design
nesse processo de design começamos com
um problema o problema geralmente
genérico o problema da escola era a os
alunos do 3º ano tinham não conseguiam
desenvolver em matemática quanto eles
precisam
tudo bem vamos para investigação
passamos para aquele passo de entender a
realidade deles sentem junto com eles
como junto com eles conversei com eles
vive com eles para entender realmente
qualquer um problema que ele está
vivendo
pensei em 10 para resolver usei
ferramentas que me ajudaram até muito
mais idéias do que eu era capaz de ter
ferramentas e fez uma coisa geralmente
ambiente para que eu fui tentar tirar de
cima das idéias para trazer para o mundo
real
eu criei protótipos comecei a
experimentar a trazer do mundo
imaginário pelo mundo real
escolhemos uma idéia trabalhamos em cima
dos detalhes
construímos levamos para a escola e deu
tudo errado uma vez que tudo errado
pegamos aqueles problemas que foram
gerados e continuamos o ciclo quando é
continuar esse ciclo é começou a criar
coisas muito legais que a gente começou
a criar por exemplo como criou esse
microscópio que aqui nessa versão era um
pouco mais caro mas que depois depois
esse ciclo de design
ele acabou se tornando um microscópio de
dois dólares que pode ser utilizado em
sala de aula
então um celular e um salão laser a
gente constrói um aparato que consegue
ser um microscópio de dois dólares
ali é o connell provou que foi um
protótipo que também deu muito certo que
era pra você trabalhar com um com as
crianças sendo mais colaborativas ainda
sadia
e esse aqui foi um dos jogos que a gente
criou o que deu mais certo é que foi um
jogo que a gente as crianças têm muito
problema para trabalhar com tabuada de
uma forma que encontrou de trabalhar com
moda fazendo correr porque gostava de
correr
ela está a preferida dela era de
educação física então vamos colocar
educação física junto com matemática
queremos um jogo que tinha que correr
para poder resolver equações matemáticas
agora legal
queremos produzir sensacionais coisas
muito legais para educação de lá mas
isso foi real valor que eu aprendi de
ter passado um mês
imerso na kombi não não foi nem pra mim
nem pra diana
a professora que quando começou todo o
processo ela começou super gente mas os
professores aqui não querem trabalhar
eles a todo nada funciona que ninguém é
todo mundo muito resistente ela começou
como um processo muito assim ela começou
dizendo que ela não tinha idéias
ela começou desacreditada nela conforme
vai passando esses parte do processo
tudo isso foi se quebrando e ainda não
eu também consigo criar também conseguiu
transformar uma realidade eu também
consigo mudar a minha escola e no final
do processo estava tão poderá da que ela
falava 'não eu vou puxar esse projeto e
vou levar essa metodologia para dentro
da escola
vou levar esse tipo de abordagem da
educação com os meus alunos ali morava o
ouro de uma educação para a inovação ali
morava o ouro de empoderamento pelo
design
aí eu entendi o que era empoderamento do
design ali entende que o ato como
poderia fazer para transformar a
educação
tudo bem passou a sair da colômbia volta
do brasil
como é que eu levo isso de volta à
realidade do nosso país
o cara tem diversas formas eu encontrei
através do movimento bem e levando para
as escolas trazer essa abordagem trazer
essa visam trazer esse tipo de
metodologia
mas cada professor pode encontrar sua
maneira diferente de trazer uma visão da
inovação
qualquer grande chave que a gente tem
que quebrar a cabeça para que a gente
possa formar inovadores seja através da
cultura minc seja através da robótica
seja através da programação seja através
da arte como é que achava que a gente
tem que mudar
a gente tem que sair da chave dos
produtos nos processos
de pensar pessoas criando solução para
pessoas através de processos todos esses
inovadores eles tinham processos mentais
modelos mentais que fazer com que eles
criassem as coisas absurdas porque com
ela mas que é uma pessoa que consegue
criar várias inovações em série porque o
modelo mental muito claro de como é que
ele queria as coisas se a gente
conseguir criar nos padrões de modelos
mentais nas crianças que eles possam ser
inovativos inovadores assim a gente vai
conseguir pensar na educação realmente
transformadora e uma coisa que eu tenho
certeza que eu aprendi com o movimento
make é o seguinte a gente não pode
pensar em construir uma educação fora da
caixa
se a gente não conseguir nem construir
uma caixa
então o que deixa para vocês é a idéia
de que a gente tem que aprender a
construir taxas pra gente poder
construir caixas ainda obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]